my name is of the 11 and possessive
international political economy at imd
business school in Switzerland my
nationality is stretch I think that the
question or the answer the question
depends on how long the crisis months in
other words i think that the tube
political situation in east asia his
fragile as we know there's more for
flights but really by and large over the
course of the last few decades it has
been managed reasonably well if one
thinks of for example I want what I have
different things about disputes in the
South China Sea the exception of course
is North Korea but there I think we may
be seeing is the scenario involving
which might indicate some devices that
particular regime however if the crisis
persists particularly if the available
but what then I think we could be
talking about geopolitical animate
mental risks of a syllable